6 26 in your wednesday morning hey we're
about to get real
about real id you may remember a recent
story we had about renewing your
driver's license online
well larry sent me an email saying hey
can you get that star on your license
online too or do you have to go in to
show proof of identity
of course he is talking about that real
id sure hope you've heard about that
i checked with kevin malone from the dnv
he says yes you do have to upgrade to a
real id
only in person there is a website for
that it's called
get getrealnevada.com and that website
explains that back in 2005 congress
passed the real id
act that sets standards for the issuance
of sources of identification such as
driver's licenses americans going to
need a real id compliant driver's
license or another accepted form of id
to get through airport security or enter
secure federal buildings
just to make sure you're up to date the
deadline for getting that real id
recently
extended to may 3rd of 2023 thanks for
writing in larry
thanks for the clarification from kevin
at the dmv we have a link to the get
real nevada website on our website
eightnewsnow.com you click traffic then
driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully and please put
on the phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com